[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى الاخبار الساعه من العربيه
وهذه عناوين
منافسا فاجنر في مخمو تنتشر روسي يفتحوا
جبهه في فوليدر باقليم دوناتس
واستغلالا لفرصه الحرب شركاتو
معدات لاوكرانيا دون تصريح من البنتا
وزير الخارجات السعوديه يؤكد سعي المملكه
لحل الخلافات مع ايران ما ينعكس ايجابا
على المنطقه
مكرون يساعد في مواجهه الشارع وعمال النطق
الفرنسيون يمنعون الناقلات من الحصول على
الامدادات
[موسيقى]
منذ بدايه الحرب على اوكرانيا لم تتوقف
الولايات المتحده عن الانفاق بسخاء على
تشليح اوكرانيا حزمه مساعدات بالجمله صادق
عليها الكونجرس الامريكي قبل ان تبدا
الشركات المصنعه للاسلحه بارسالها الى كيف
لكن تصميم الشركات الامريكيه على زياده
حصتها من مبيعات الاسلحه لاوكرانيا دفع
بعضها الى نقل اسلحتها بشكل مباشر دون
انتظار التصاريح الاداريه اللازمه من
البنتا من بين هذه الشركات شركه سايبر
لاكس وهي شركه مصنعه للمسيرات
ونقلا عن صحيفه
للاسلحه كانت قد ابدت رغبه في تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه لكن شروط البنتاجون
حاله دون ذلك فوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
تفرض مرور جميع الامدادات عبر قنواتها كما
انها تشترط ارسال المساعدات وفق حاجيات
اوكرانيا وليس بشكل اعتباطي لكن شركه صعبه
المتمركزه في ولايه كارولاين الشماليه
اخترقت روتين العسكري لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ونقلت مسيراتها الاستطلاعيه
مباشره الى الاوكرانيين
كيف قامت هذه الشركات ببيع اسلحتها الى
اوكرانيا بدايه يقوم بعض الوسطاء بربط
الاتصال بين الشركه وكبار المسؤولين في
كييف وغالبا ما يكون الوسطاء عباره عن
خبراء اسلحه بعدها يقوم مشروع شركات
الامريكيه بالتوجه الى كييف ومقابله
المسؤولين العسكريين وعرض السلاح الذي
تريد بيعه وفي حال ما لقى سلاح اعجاب
المسؤولين الاوكران فان الشركات الامريكيه
تقوم بالتحايل على البنتاجون من خلال شحن
اسلحتها عبر شركات النقل وارسالها مباشره
الى اوكرانيا
وبهذه الطريقه شحنت شركه سايبر لاكس مثلا
اسلحتها الى كييف لكن وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه علمت بالموضوع وقامت بعدها
بتوبيخ الشركه من خلال تصنيفها كشركه
مضلله رغما داله تراجع قيمه اسومها بشكل
كبير الغريب في الامر ان حزمه المساعدات
الاخيره التي صادق عليها الكونجرس شمل
الطائرات الشركه نفسها رغم التحايل الذي
قامت به ويبدو بان الامر متعلق بطلب كييف
فضلا عن الاقبال الكبير على الطائرات بدون
طيار خصوصا خلال هذه الحرب
توقع تقرير لمعهد دراسات الحرب في واشنطن
ان يسعى الجيش الروسي الى القضاء على
مقاتله باجنر في ساحات المعارك في
اوكرانيا وذلك ضمن استمرار تصاعد التوتر
بين الجيش
[موسيقى]
ليست هذه الجبهه الوحيده المشتعله على
اطراف ضخمه فالخطوط الخلفيه بين فاجنر
والجيش الروسي مستعره بتقاذف الاتهامات
بعضها تجاوز الخطوط الحمر الناس يجب ان
يمتلكوا حريه التعبير عن ارائهم الجنود
العاديون هم الوحيدون فوق اي انتقاد تصريح
وصف بقنبله من العيار الثقيل لمتزعم قوات
فاجنر الروسيه في اخر تطور للخلافات
الدائره بينه وبين قياده الجيش الروسي
اعتقد ان قانون مكافحه التشويه السمعه يجب
ان لا يسري على اركان القياده اي انا
ووزير الدفاع والقاده الاخرين الذين
يرتكبون او يمكن ان يرتكبوا الاخطاء اثناء
عمليات عسكريه خاصه
بريجوجين لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل ذهب في
هجومه الجديد الى اتهام قياده الجيش
الروسي بمنع حتى معاوي لحفر الخنادق عن
عناصر فيتنار بامر جعل القتال والتقدم
صعبين عليهم
وفقا لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه فان تصميم
الجيش الروسي للسيطره على بلده فوهليدار
بدونيسك ياتي في اطار التنافس بين
الجانبين ومحاوله لمضاهات فاجنر فيباخمت
كذلك توقع تحليل لمعهد دراسات الحرب في
واشنطن ان يسعى الجيش الروسي للقضاء على
مقاتل فاغنر في ساحات القتال بينما توقع
تقرير امريكي ان تصبح فاجنر قوه عسكريه
موازيه للجيش الروسي بعد ضمها 50 الف
مقاتل مع استمرار تقاذف الاتهامات بين
الطرفين تبقى جبهه اوكرانيا صامده الى حين
نهايه المعركه بين فاغنر والجيش
من القاهره احمد علي بالبحث في وحده
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
استاذ احمد الكل يسعى الى نيل ثقه بوتين
في المعركه الدائره في اوكرانيا ولكن هل
ستصل المساله الى ان تقوم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بتوريط باجنر اكثر والتخلي عنها
بعدم دعمها بسلاح وفي المعارك من اجل
التقليص من امكانيات هذه الميليشيا
مساء الخير اولا يعني اتصور انه نحن نشاهد
دراما واضحه تماما ما بين قوات فاجنر وما
بين الجيش الروسي لكن في الاخير الرئيس
بوتين يستفيد من توظيف كلا الطرفين
ويستفيد من هذه المنافسه في اكثر من امر
لانه فاجنر توفر له في المرحله الحاليه
يعني دور في معادله الاستنزاف ما بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه لانه
معدل استنزاف القوات ومعدل استنزاف
الاسلحه والذخيره اذا ما كان مع الجيش
كانت المعادله سوف تختلف كثيرا بالتاكيد
كان الجيش الروسي سوف يعاني من هذا الامر
الى حد كبير المساله الاخرى تتعلق بالكلفه
ايضا لانه فاجنر لديها موارد وشاهدنا
قائد فاجنر وهو يطلب من الجرشه الروسيه
مساله التمويل لكن على الجانب الاخر لا
اعتقد انه القوات المسلحه الروسيه تريد ان
تكون فاجنر منافسا لها شاهدنا هذا ايضا مع
كادراف الرئيس الشيشانيه الذي انتقد
القوات الروسيه من قبل وكان يريد ان يظهر
بمنظر القائد ندا
امر غير اعتيادي في بعد الخلفاء عندما
انتقدروف القوات الروسيه ايضا قائد فاجنر
انتقد بشكل صريح وزير الدفاع الروسي هل
هذه الانتقادات هي فقط لكسب رضا بوتين ام
ان هناك بالفعل تصفيه حسابات بين جميع تلك
الاطراف
يعني اتصور انه كلا الفردتين من الممكن ان
يكون واردا لسبب لانه فاجنر ربما عملت مع
القوات الروسيه في ساحات مختلفه عملت معها
في روسيا عملت معها في مالي لكنها كانت
تقوم في الاخير بمهام لوجستيه الان هي
تقوم بمهام قتاليه رئيسيه في معركه مهمه
وهي معركه تغمض وبالتالي
استطيع ان اقول انه هي اصبحت منافس ايضا
هي تعمل الان على
يعني زياده حجمها بشكل كبير فتحت اكثر من
مكتبا للتعبئه العسكريه
والتعاقدات مع مجندين ربما او عناصر
المقاتله ربما قد لا يكون لديهم الرغبه في
ان يندمجوا في الجيش لانه هناك مقابل
لهؤلاء مقاتلين بالاجر في الاخير وبالتالي
هناك اغراءات تقدمها فيجن لكن ان يفتح لها
اكثر من 40 مكتبه هذا يعني يشكل نوع من
التنافس مع الجيش فيما يتعلق بعمليه
التعبئه المتعثره او التي تعثرت من قبل
وبالتالي هذه المؤشرات كلها تفيد بانه
بالفعل هناك نوع من
الحساسيات الواضحه تماما ما بين الطرفين
العامل الاخر انه اذا تمكنت بالفعل من حسم
معركه ضخمه سوف يكون هذا رصيدا اضافيا
بالنسبه لها لانه الجيش قبل ان تصل فاجنر
الى مسرح كان
لم يتمكن من حسم هذه المعركه على مدار
اكثر من شهرين ونصف الشهر وبالتالي انا
اعتقد انها سوف تكون منافس قوي وانا اعتقد
انها تحاول ان تثبت وجودها في هذه
المساحه حتى ولو كان ذلك بتكلفه كبيره
لانه هذا لا يعنيه انا اعتقد انه الهدف
الاستراتيجي بالنسبه لقياده فاجنر هي
اثبات الوجود هي اث بات انه لديه قدره على
انه يشكل متغير في ساحه المعركه ان هو
يكسب بالفعل ود الكرملين ان هو يستطيع ان
يكون طرفا في المعادله حتى في المستقبل ما
بعد معركه ضخمه الكل يسعى الى رضا الكريمي
ولكن من يحقق الانتصارات هو من سيخضع
برضاء بوتين احمد علي بالبحث في وحده
الدراسات العسكريه في مركز الاهرام شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اخر من الازمه يبدو ان الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه ستحظى بترقب غير مسبوق
من طرف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
فنتائجها قد تغير مجرى الحرب بشكل كلي
سيابا في حال فوز احد المرشحين الرئيسيين
للحزب الجمهوري دونالد ترامب وروننا
ديسانتس فكلاهما غير مؤيد للحرب بالاساس
ترامب نفسه كان واضحا بخصوص موقفه من
الحرب حيث قال انه سينهيها في غضون 24
ساعه اذا تولى رئاسه الولايات المتحده اما
ديسانتس فاوضح ان المزيد من التورط في
نزاع اقليمي بين روسيا واوكرانيا ليس في
مصلحه الولايات المتحده هذا وتفيد
استطلاعات لصحيفه
عند موقف الناخبين الجمهوريين بدات تتجهوا
نحو مناهضه الحرب فاقل من 40% فقط يؤيدون
استمرار واشنطن في تزويد كيرب بالاسلحه
ولا شك ان موقف الجمهوريين من الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا في الحرب يبدو اقل
تاييدا قياسا بموقف الديمقراطيين فمن
المرتقب ان تنفذ واشنطن خلال الخريف
المقبل تموينا الى اوكرانيا بقيمه 45
مليار دولار كان اقره الكونجرس في ديسمبر
وهي الحزمه التي لن ترقى كثيرا او لم ترق
كثيرا للجمهوريين حينها حضر كيفن مكافي
الرئيس الجمهوري لمجلس النواب من تقديم
شركات على بياض لاوكرانيا ونقلا عن صحيفه
يمني نفسه في فوز الجمهوريين حيث يتوقع ان
تجف بعدها امدادات امريكا من المال
والاسلحه الى اوكرانيا ومن المرجح ان يكون
ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا مؤثرا في اختيارات
داخلين الامريكيين
المنقسمين بين راغب في مواصله بلاده دعم
اوكرانيا واخر يفضل وضع حد للحرب بعد
الازمات الاقتصاديه الخانقه التي تسببت
بها
[موسيقى]
رئيس روسي الرسوري هذه المراه بشار الاسد
يحط رحاله بالعاصمه الروسيه موسكو ويصافح
من جديد ابرز حلفائه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين زياره كانت الاولى من
نوعها للاسد خارج الشرق الاوسط بعد زلزال
الذي هز سوريا وتركيا زياره تحمل اكثر من
رساله في ظل التطورات الاخيره التي عرفها
شاب سوري بعد الكارثه صحيفه لوفي سلطت
الضوء على المكاسب التي حققها الاسد بعد
زلزال وذلك من خلال اعتماده على دبلوماسيه
الكوارث حسب لو في ان الاسد نجح في توظيف
الزلزال لكسر حزلته الاقليميه
روسيا بدورها لا تزال تحاول جاهده نحو
الدفع من اجل كسر العزل على النظام السوري
وموسكو تقوم بمحاولات جاده من اجل الدفع
نحو تطبيع العلاقات بين دمشق وانقره من
خلال ترتيب لقاءات رسميه تمهيديه بين
الجانبين ايضا الاستقبال الرسمي الذي حظي
به الاسد لدى وصوله الى موسكو يعد دليلا
على رغبه روسيا في اضافه شرعيه اكبر على
النظام السوري وكان بشار الاسد قد قام
مؤخرا بزياره رسميه الى سلطنه عمان كما ان
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح حط الرحاله في
دمشق نهايه فبراير الماضي في اول زياره
لمسؤول مصري رفيع الى سوريا منذ بدء الحرب
في البلاد سنه 2011
ايضا في اخبار الساعه
حاكموا مصر في لبنان يفشل في التهرب من
جلسه قضائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان المملكه
تبسط يدها دائما للحوار وحل الخلافات بطرق
السلميه ومن هذا المنطلق اجرت على مدار
عامين جولات حوار مع ايران تكللت بالاتفاق
على اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤمن باهميه
ما يجمعنا من روابط الدين والجوار وتبسط
يدها دوما للحوار يحل الخلافات بالطرق
السلميه ومن هذا المنطلق اجرت لاكثر من
عامين عده جولات للحوار على الشقاء في
ايران في كل من بغداد واسقط ثم مؤخرا في
بكين وقد تكلت هذه المباحثات بالاتفاق على
اعداد الاعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلالين على اساس احترام مبادئ ومقاصد
ميثاق المتحده ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
وفي طليعه احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل
الداخليه وحسن الجوار وحل الخلافات حوار
ونتطلع الى ان يعزز هذا الاتفاق من امن
واستقرار منطقه الخليج العربي ويدعم مسيره
العمل الاسلاميه المشترك
وفيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه كذا وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه على حق الفلسطينيين في
دوله مستقله على حدود
مديرا في الوقت نفسه انتهاكات قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في حق الشعب
الفلسطيني
تؤكد المملكه موقفها الداعم للاسراع في
ايجاد الحل عالد وشامل للقضيه الفلسطينيه
وفق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه
واقامه دوله فلسطين مستقله على حدود عام
67 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه والمملكه كانت
ولا زالت تدعم الشعب الفلسطيني لاستعاده
حقوقه المشروعه
والمجتمع الدولي للقيام بدوره في وضع حد
الانتهاكات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني وتقويض فرص احياء
عمليه السلام
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على دعم المملكه
المتواصل للسلام في اليمن ولكل المجهودات
الداعيه لوصف اطلاق النار بشكل دائم
ان المملكه تجدد دعمها للسلام في اليمن
ولجهود المبعوث الامني الى اليمن الراميه
الى التوصل لوقف كامل ودائم لاطلاق النار
وبدء العمليه السياسيه بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين وتؤكد على دعم مجلس
القياده الرئاسي اليمني لتمكينه من تنفيذ
سياسات ومبادرات فعاله من شانها تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار في الجمهوريه اليمنيه
وانهاء الازمه
وبهذا الخصوص افادت صحيفه وولد ستريت جون
بموافقه ايران على وقف تسليح الحوثيين في
اطار الاتفاق على استهداف العلاقات مع
السعوديه كما اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى نهج
ايران حيال الصراع في اليمن لان هذا النهج
سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا لنوواياها بعد عوده
العلاقات مع الرياض وهذا الاتفاقيه ستعطي
دفعه للتوصل الى صفقه لانهاء النزاع في
اليمن في وقت قريب
معنا من واشنطن عبر سكايب حسين عبد الحسين
الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات
سيد حسين اهلا وسهلا بك الاخبار الساعه هل
ستكون اليمن او السلام في اليمن المحكه
الرئيسي لهذا التقارب سعودي الايراني
مساء الخير لا شك انه موضوع اليمن هو من
المواضيع الاساسيه في هذا التقارب ولا شك
انه الكلمات والاتفاقيات وحدها لا تكفي
وانه هذه الاتفاقيه سيتم الحكم عليها
بالافعال
يعني سنرى ان كانت ايران ستلتزم ان كانت
قطعت وعودا اصلا نحن لا نعرف التفاصيل
ولكن ان كانت قطعت وعود بعدم تسليح
الحوثيين وبمحاوله يعني عقلنه الحوثيين
للدخول في حوار عقلانيه للتواصل الى تسويه
ترضي جميع الاطراف اليمنيين وقت ذلك اعتقد
انه يعني قد تكون الامور في وضع افضل
بكثير مما هي عليه اليوم
وزير الخارجيه السعودي بن فرحان تحدث عن
سنتين من
المفاوضات وبالتاكيد تلك سنتان لن تكون
فقط
لعوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه لابد بان هناك
اتفاقيات تتعلق باكثر من ملف واكثر ما
ازمه اذا رتبنا الاولويه فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه بعد اليمن
الاولويه لمن
قد تكون بعض اليمن الاولويه ربما لبنان او
ربما يعني تصرفات الايران بشكل عام لانه
نحن نعرف ان الميليشيات موجوده ميليشيات
المواليه لايران موجوده في العراق وسوريا
وهي تقوم بنشاطات متعدده يعني غير اليمن
ولكن طبعا الاتفاقيه هي ليست حول عوده او
اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين
لانه نحن نعرف ان العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
كانت موجوده حتى ديسمبر لعام 2015 وفي ذلك
الوقت لم تكن ايران يعني لم تمارس افضل
التصرفات ايران التصرفات الجاره فلا شك
انه يعني اي مصالحه بين الطرفين
تتطلب الذهاب ابعد بكثير من العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه هل تلتزم ايران باي من هذه
الشروط لا نعرف يعني انا اتابع الاعلام
الايراني ويبدو انه يعتقد انه وكانه
السعوديه هي التي ستاتي الى الموقع الذي
تقف فيه ايران لا اعتقد انه يعني
معظمنا يرى الامور من هذه الوجهه ولكن
طبعا الاعلام شيء وما يجب الحديث عنه خلف
الابواب الموصده شيء اخر وكلنا امل ان
تكون ايران فعلا قطعت وعوده ستلتزم بها مع
المملكه بالتاكيد بين الاعلام الايراني
سيسعى الى ما ذكرت لان سنوات طويله من
العداه شيطنه المنطقه تحتاج الى نظره اخرى
من قبل الاعلام الايراني ولكن ان يكون هذا
التقارب برعايه
صينيه هل سيغضب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ام ان من مصلحه واشنطن ايضا ان
يكون هناك تقارب واستقرار في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
ليس بالضروره ان يغضب الولايات المتحده
ولكن اعتقد انه الصين ستكون امام امتحان
في حال تعرضت المملكه او امن المملكه او
مصالح المملكه في المنطقه لاي اعتداء من
ايران او من الميليشيات المواليه لايران
يمكن للمملكه ان تحمل هذه الوثيقه
المصالحه وتذهب بها الى الصين وتقول لها
هذا توقيعكم على الوثيقه وانتم تكفلونها
وطبعا نحن نعرف انه ايران مرتبطه باتفاقيه
اتفاقيه اقتصاديه استراتيجيه مدتها 25
عاما مع الصين وهي تعتمد الى حد كبير
اقتصاديا والى حد كبير ايضا دبلوماسيا
وسياسيا على الصين لدى الصين قدره اكثر
على ممارسه ضغوط على ايران ولذلك اقحام
الصين في هذه الاتفاقيه اعتقد انها خطوه
حكيمه ولكن طبعا كما قلت العبره تبقى في
التنفيذ ان كان من الناحيه الايرانيه والى
حد ما من ناحيه الصين
حصير عبد الحسين الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
انتهت اول جلسه استجواب لرياض سلامه بحضور
وفد القضاء الاوروبي القاضي شربل ابو سمره
حدد صباح الجمعه موعدا جديدا لمثور سلام
امام الوفود القضائيه الاوروبيه مره اخرى
بينما انتظر الاعلاميون على مدخل قصر
العدل اصول حاكم مصر في لبنان الرياض
سلامه الذي حضر مكرها لجلسه استجواب حول
اتهامات طالته دخل سلام من باب خلفي بعيدا
عن عدسات كانت حاضره لرصته
في الداخل وفد اوروبي متسلح بمئه سؤال
رفعها قاض لبناني حفاظا على سياده الدوله
اجاب سلامي على ما طرح من اسئله في جلسه
وصفتها مصادر بالهادئه نحن بانتظار انتهاء
لتحقيق اوروبا بالموضوع وبعد عوده القضاه
الاوروبيين الى بلادهم بنشوف شو هو القرار
اللي حيعتبر انه في جرم على رياضيات سليم
شو هو هذا الجرم حجم الجرم شو هو وهل حيتم
اتخاذ اجراءات بحقه وتبليغ الانتربول
واخيرا حضر سلمه اول مسؤول رفيع المستوى
يخضع للاستجواب في بلد لطالما تفلت مساله
من العقاب ومرت جرائمه الماليه والجنائيه
من دون محاسبه ومثول سلام اليوم وان كان
كشاهد هو مشهد غريب على اللبناني
اعتقد اللعبه وصلت الى نقطه لا رجوع فيها
رياض سلامه لا تستطيع السلطه
المنظومه ان تحميه
لان القضاء الاجنبي وضع يده ايضا على
القضيه لو تركت للقضاء المحلي
لامكن رياض سلامه ان يبقى في منصبه وان
يتابع سياسته الماليه وان يستمر في خدمه
من يحميه من اعضاء السلطه
كلامي انهاء جلساته على عجل على ان تستكمل
لاحقا مع شقيق الرجل
ومساعدته مريم الحويك غنوه يتيم العربيه
[موسيقى]
وحكومته يوم الراني بمشروع قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد يمررانه دون تصويت البرلمان
غضب في الشارع تهديدات لنوابل يسار واغسل
يميل بمذكرات حجم الثقه عن الحكومه
والنقابات تتوعد لتصعيد في الشارع
حسمت الحكومه الفرنسيه امرها ومررت مشروع
قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد من دون تصويت
البرلمان ما فجر تظاهرات غاضبه عفويه امام
البرلمان انضم اليها نواب اليسار الفرنسي
في الطريق الى التظاهره وقف نواب اليسار
على بعد امتار من حاجز امني ورددوا النشيد
الوطني بعدها بدقائق وصل الزعيم اليساري
الاكثر جدلا وشعبيه في فرنسا جانوك
ميلانشو لتتعالى صيحات الترحيب به
سنقوم بطرح مذكره حجب ثقه عن الحكومه هذا
نص ليست له شرعيه تم اعتماده في مجلس
الشيوخ لكن لم يوافق عليه مجلس النواب
تمرير الحكومه لمشروعها من دون تصويت مجلس
النواب كان خيارا لكنه لم يكن متوقعا بهذا
الشكل فلوحت المعارضه اليساريه بمذكرات
حجم الثقه عن الحكومه وكذلك فعلت زعيمه
اقصى اليمين مارين لوبتان
هناك نواب من كتله الاكثريه الرئاسيه
معارضون لمشروع القانون تم تهديدهم
لاجبارهم على التصويت بنعم هذا حصل ايضا
لدى الجمهوريين النقابات اعلنت جاهزيتها
للتصعيد بهدف الوصول الى شل الاقتصاد
سنقوم بشل الاقتصاد هذا ما نخطط لفعله
حاليا وايضا ستكون هناك تحركات في قطاع
الطاقه خصوصا البترول سنقوم بفعل كل شيء
لتصعيد الغضب
بذلك تدخل فرنسا مرحله جديده من عداء شارع
المعارضه للحكومه والرئيس ما قد ينذر
بانفجار شعبي سيتحمل الرئيس والحكومه
بعاته بحسب ما تهدد النقابات فدهوك
العربيه باريس
وفيطار هذا التصعيد اغلق عمال النفط في
فرنسا الطريق المؤدي الى احد مستودعات
النفط في البلاد لمنع ناقلات من اخذ
الامدادات النفطيه احتجاج
[موسيقى]
التوترات في المحيط الهادئ تتصاعد يوما
بعد اخر واجهات العبد واجهات عند معده
معنيه بهذا الصراع ابرزها الصين واليابان
هذه المره جاءت دور على وزاره الدفاع
الصينيه لاتهام السلطات اليابانيه بالعوده
الى المسار العسكري المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه اعتبر ان اليابان عمدت
خلال السنوات الماضيه تحت غطاء ما سميته
بتهديدات الخارجيه الى تعزيز الميزانيتها
وقدراتها الدفاعيه بشكل كبير كما ادعى ذات
المتحدث طوكيو الى توخي الحذر في كل
افعالها التي قد تمس امن وسلام المنطقه
بدورها دانه الخارجيه الصينيه تصرفات
اليابانيه في بحر الصين الشرقي سينما
قيمها بنشر القوات الدفاع الذاتي في منطقه
نائيه قريبه من جزر سينكا كو المتنازع
عليه
يلا انشطه زلزاليه لا تزال متواصله فبعد
زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا زلزال
عنيف يضرب نيوزلندا بقوه
7.10 درجه ليزيد من حده القلق بخصوص
تداعيات الهزات الارضيه على قشره الارض
دراسه علميه كشفت ان الزلازل المستمره
تسببت في اتساع صدع موجود في افريقيا
تابعه تفاصيل مع فارس صلوات
اخبار الكوارث الطبيعيه لا تتوقف افريقيا
القاره قد تنشطر الى نصفين هذا وفق تقرير
اعده باحثون بريطانيون ونشر في دوريه
لكن لا داعي للفزع فهذا الامر قد يستغرق
بين خمسه الى عشره ملايين سنه والسبب هو
الزلازل التي ادت الى تصدعات في قشره
الارض اخرها الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا وخلف نحو 50 الف قتيل
هذا الزلزال وصل التداعياته الى القاره
السمراء زلزال تركيا وسوريا وقع بين ثلاثه
صفائح تيكتونيه وتسبب في تحرك صفيحه
الاناضول ثلاثه امتار غربا وادى ايضا الى
تحرك الصفيحه الافريقيه وساهم في اتساع ما
يعرف بصدع الشرق افريقيا الذي اصبح اكثر
نشاطا مع تزايد الحركه مستمره داخل القشره
الارضيه الصدع يبلغ طوله سته وخمسين كيلو
مترا او 56 كيلومترا وظهر في الصحاري
الاثيوبيه في عام 2018
يمتد نشطه في شرق افريقيا اسفل كل من
اثيوبيا وكينيا وتنزانيا حيث تشير دراسات
الى ان تحركات الصفائح قد بدات من منطقه
عفار شمال اثيوبيا وانتشرت جنوبا نحو
زيمبابوي وبمعدل يتراوح بين السنتيمترين
ونصف الى خمسه سنتيمترات سنويا هذا
الامتداد يقع فوق نقطه تقاطع ثلاث صفائح
التكتونيه تتقشر ببطء شديد وتنزلق بعيدا
عن بعضها البعض وهي عمليه جيولوجيه معقده
يقول العلماء بانها ستقسم القاره السمراء
الى قسمين ما يحدث في الصدع يمثل تماما
الحركه التي كونت البحر الاحمر ولكن بمعدل
اكثر بطئا وفقا ما نشر في دوريه جيوفسكا
جورنال وخلص او وخلص العلماء القائمون على
الدراسه الى ان تشكيل محيط جديد في
افريقيا يمكن ان يكون وهو امر مرجح وبعدها
سيتقدم قاع البحر على طول الصدى هنا ستصبح
القره الافريقيه اصغر حجما وستشكل جزيره
كبيره في المحيط الهندي تضم اجزاء من
اثيوبيا والصومال وكذا القرن الافريقي
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
ضربه قادره لسيري واليكسا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رفض قاضي محكمه جنائيه
في العاصمه الباكستانيه سلامه
وجدد القاضي قرار المحكمه بضروره مثول خان
امامها خلال الجلسه المقبله
الان في الطريق الرئيسيه المجاور لمنزل
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني عمران خان كما
ترون الحياه عادت الى طبيعتها في هذا
المكان لكن باستثناء هذا الزحام
اقف الان امام بعض الخيام التي اقامها
حزبا نصاب زعامه عمران خان لاستقبال
انصاره الذين جاءوا هنا للتعبير عن موقفهم
وتضامنهم مع رئيس الوزراء السابق كما ترون
هنا يتواجد هنا مختلف شرائح المجتمع
الباكستاني الذين جاءوا هنا للتعبير عن
تضامنهم مع رئيس وزراء السابق
هذه هي البوابه الرئيسيه لمنزل رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان هنا
يحتشد العشرات من انصاره على مدار الساعه
هنا تاتي عدد من المجموعات من مختلف
المناطق الباكستانيه للتعبير عن تضامنها
مرددين متافات مؤيده لعمران خان ومناوئه
للحكومه
[تصفيق]
هذه خيمه الاعتصام الرئيسيه لانصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان بعض المعاصمين
جاءوا من مناطق مختلفه وبعضهم يمكث هنا
منذ عده ايام دعما لرئيس الوزراء السابق
وتحسبا لاي اجراءات قد تقوم بها الشرطه
لاعتقال زعيمهم
[موسيقى]
وكما ترون يحمل العديد من انصار رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
الهرواتي والعصي التي يقولون انها للدفاع
عن النفس ضد قمع الشرطه وبالرغم من ان
الاوضاع قد تبدو هادئه فان هذا الهدوء
ربما هو الذي يسبق العاصفه عبد الرحمن
المزيني العربيه لاهور
[موسيقى]
وباط الاداره الامريكيه باي دانسا صينيه
شركه الام لتيك توك بين خيارات صعبه فاما
بيع التطبيق الواسع الانتشار او مواجهه
الحضره الكامل في امريكا جاهد الانذار
النهائي لتيك توك من قبل الوكاله
الامريكيه المكلفه بتقييم المخاطر التي
تمثلها الاستثمارات الاجنبيه على الامن
القومي
وبحسب ما نقلت صحيفه
فان تيك توك الذي لديه اكثر من 100 مليون
مستخدم في الولايات المتحده يدعي ان
بيانات المستخدمين محميه كما ينفي
باستمرار مشاركه بياناته مع الحكومه
الصيني
في المقابل قال المدير التنفيذي لتيك توك
شوزي شو ان عمليه بيع تيك توك لن تحل
مخاوف الامن القومي الامريكي من شركه ماي
الصينيه المالكه للتطبيق وفقا لصحيفه
اكثر من الخطه التي وضعها تيك توك التي
تتضمن الاستعانه بشريك امريكي
الفرنسيه فراس الحاج يحيى الباحث الحقوقي
سيد فراس اهلا وسهلا بك هذا الجدل كيف
سينتهي هل بيع تيك توك لشركه غير صينيه
سيحل هذه المشكله وسيحمي الامن القومي الى
بركه
تحياتي لحضرتك ولجميع الساده المشاهدين
الحظر الامريكي اليوم او الطلب الامريكي
من شركه
اسهم في تطبيق تيك توك الى شركه امريكيه
يعني او مواجهه حظر حظروا حقيقه يدفعنا
لعديد من التساؤلات حول
يعني ماهيه هذا القرار على الرغم من اهميه
اهميه ولكن بذات الوقت يعني بالمجال
الحقوقي هذا يعتبر مساومه على بعض الحقوق
المتعلقه بالانتهاكات التي قد يجت تسببها
هذا التطبيق تطبيق تيك توك يعني يعني
المخاوف الاساسيه من التي موجوده هي
انتهاك خصوصيه المستخدمين وعدم وايضا عدم
احترام الحقوق الملكيه الفكريه والمحتوى
الغير ملائم للاطفال بالتالي من حق
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالدرجه
الاولى حمايه امن القومي وهذا ايضا واجب
لها وعفوا واجب عليها
الارتباطات الموجوده لدى ماريكيه شركه تيك
توك
وعلاقتهم المعروفه
بالنظام الصيني تضع او تجعل من واجب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تتدخل
لحمايه امن القومي والحمايه مواطنيه
وبيانات مواطنيها قامت تيك توك
او شركه ببيع التطبيق لشركه ملكيه
وبالتالي ربما الى حد ما استطعنا حمايه
الامن القومي الامريكي ولكن من سيحمي
حقوقها بقيه العالم هل ستطالب فرنسا ببيع
تطبيق من شركه امريكيه الى شركه فرنسيه او
مثلا السعوديه الى شركه سعوديه من اجل
حمايه المستخدمين ام ان مثلا تطبيقات مثل
فيسبوك انستغرام تويتر تطبيقات لا تؤثر
على الامن القومي لتلك الدول
في مزاع انتهاك خصوصيه بيانات مستخدمين من
قبل شركه بايت دانس ايضا المفوضيه
الاوروبيه حظها يعني حضرت تحميل
تطبيق تيك توك على اجهزه هواتف موظفه
موظفيها منظمه حمايه المستهلك الامن
الاوروبيه قدمت شكوى الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد
تيك توك بسبب سياسه الخصوصيه يعني
الموجوده في تيك توك وغير الشفافه وايضا
الاعلانات المضلل المضلله وبيع بيانات
المستخدمين وبالتالي السؤال هنا او يعني
كيفيه التعامل مع هذه القضيه لا تكون من
خلال يعني عقد اتفاقات مع على حساب
حمايه الامن القومي الامريكي لا تعني
حمايه الامن القومي لبقيه الدول في العالم
فراس الحاج يحيى الباحث الحقوقي شكرا
جزيلا لك
وبينما تبرز تكنولوجيا جديده تخطف الانظار
بشكل كبير مثل تطبيق
لم تستطع تقريرات اخرى فرضا نفسها ليخفت
بريقها بشكل كبير ابرز تقنيات التي خيبت
الامال هي ميزات المساعدين الافتراضيين
المدعومين بذكاء الاصطناعي والتي سجلت
ركودا كبيرا خصوصا نقلا عن المساعدين
الافتراضيين مثل سيري لابل واليكسا من
امازون وجوجل اسيستنت اصبحت محل انتقاد
واسع وصف الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
مايكروسوفت ساتيا المساعدين الصوتيين
الافتراضيين بانهم اغبياء مثل الصخر
[موسيقى]
شكرا زياده معنا لمتابعه هذا الخبر العلمي
الجديد الابحاث العلميه تقود الى التعرف
على اطول رقبه عبر الوجود والتي تعود الى
عهد الديناصورات بالطبع تحليل جديد لعظام
ديناصور كشف انه كان يمتلك اطول عنق لاي
كاهن على الاطلاق فرقبته كانت تمتد لاكثر
من 15 مترا وكانت اطول بسبع مرات من عنق
زرافه بالغه هذا الديناصور الذي يقدر وزنه
ب 19 قدنا وجد على الارض قبل حوالي 160
مليون سنه وانقرض منذ حوالي 66 مليون سنه
[موسيقى]
في الختام تذكيرا بالعناوه
منافسا فقرر في باخمه الجيش الروسي يفتحوا
جبهه في فوليدر
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه وقد سعي المملكه
لحل الخلافات مع ايران ما ينعكس ايجابا
على المنطقه
نهايه اخبار الساعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]